[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend wenn man mit
geheimdienstleuten redet dann stößt man
schnell auf so eine
eindeutige zweideutigkeit wer hinter
bestimmten aktionen steckt wer was wie
eingefädelt hat auf konkrete fragen
kommt dann dieses wissenden lächeln
einerseits ist geheimdienstarbeit
natürlich geheim andererseits haben die
beteiligten manchmal durchaus ein
interesse daran ihre eigene rolle
zumindest anzudeuten aus dem weißen haus
in washington heißt es offiziell wir
helfen der ukraine so gut und so schnell
wie möglich jetzt kommen immer mehr
details ans licht die zeigen wie konkret
diese unterstützung bei
militäroperationen bereits ist und dass
sie weiter geht als bisher bekannt war
aus washington el mati wissen
das pentagon hat löcher wie ein
schweizer käse sensible informationen
sickern heraus manchmal sogar in
hintergrundgesprächen an denen dutzende
journalisten auch wie ihr teilnehmen die
moskwa stolz der russischen flotte soll
vom ukrainischen militär auch dank
amerikanischer aufklärungsdaten versenkt
worden sein kaum ist die meldung draußen
muss pentagon-sprecher körper offiziell
stellung nehmen
die vereinigten staaten geben den
ukrainischen streitkräften schlachtfeld
aufklärung damit sie ihr land
verteidigen können keine aufenthaltsorte
von russischen militärführern wir
beteiligen uns auch nicht an der
zielauswahl
david koubbi in die morgen schoß des
us-fernsehens der ehemalige
konteradmiral betreibt
schadensbegrenzung
darüber aufklärung rede ist dann ist
weniger besser wenn wir der ukraine
weiter helfen wollen müssen wir solche
informationen schützen darüber zu reden
ist total unverantwortlich
dass die usa und ihre verbündeten
entscheidende hinweise liefern ist
unbestritten sie hören sogar die
komplette kommunikation im
konfliktgebiet ab ihre e8 jazz stars und
ihre unbemannten global hawk drohnen und
die in extremer höhe fliegenden u2
maschinen starten von stützpunkten in
großbritannien italien und deutschland
die informationen gehen dann aus werther
auf nato basen in osteuropa von dort an
die ukrainischen partner
und die regierung will aber nicht den
einzelheiten gehen welcher art und wie
aber wir wollen sicherstellen dass die
ukraine erfolgreich ist
der ukrainische hubschrauber angriff auf
russische öl lager in belgorod kaum
möglich ohne daten aus nato-flugzeugen
ebenso wie die tödlichen angriffe auf
russische generäle trotz aller dementis
denn die hinweise auf amerikanische
hilfe kamen aus seinen behörden und
experten rätseln warum der präsident so
wenig tut um die lecks zu stopfen
es kommt anscheinend aus
regierungsquellen sie wollen die russen
wohl wissen lassen dass hervorragende us
aufklärung zweifellos die beste in der
welt den ukrainern auf dem schlachtfeld
bewegungsmuster zeigen derzeit
aufklärungsflugzeuge bei einer stelle im
schwarzen meer die ukraine behauptet
ihre raketen hätten die russische
fregatte admiral makarow getroffen ob
das pentagon auch damit etwas zu tun hat
darauf gibt es keinen hinweis jedenfalls
noch nicht
da bringen wir unsere korrespondenten
mit dazu in washington und in moskau
matti wissen zunächst zu dir kann der
beiden regierung denn daran gelegen sein
dass das jetzt alles öffentlich wird
ich glaube ja trotz aller dementis der
adressat ist nämlich eigentlich wladimir
putin und der soll kurz vor den
feierlichkeiten am 9 bei wohl wissen wie
gezielt und auch wie entschlossen die
usa und die verbündeten dazwischen gehen
würden wenn beispielsweise russische
truppen den krieg aus denen auf das
territorium von moldau beispielsweise
das soll also gewissermaßen abschrecken
von einer ausdehnung dieses krieges nun
wäre es dann sehr kontraproduktiv wenn
man sich gleichzeitig dann vor laufenden
kameras auch noch freuen würde über
diese erfolge und deswegen wird so etwas
erzeugt wie eine man nennt das
strategische uneindeutigkeit hauptsache
am ende kommt das signal an da wo es
ankommen soll nämlich in moskau ja dann
gucken wir doch mal ob und wie das
signal ankommt in moskau christiansen
wie reagiert denn der präsident auf
diese berichte
putin selbst hat sich dazu noch nicht
geäußert seine sprecher hat sich dazu
geäußert paskov und hat das ganze ein
bisschen er runter gespielt hat gesagt
na ja es sei allseits bekannt dass die
amerikaner die briten und auch die nato
die ukraine auch mit informationen
versorgen neben den waffen das wird aber
nichts daran ändern dass man seine
militärischen ziele dieser
sonderoperation ukraine erreichen werde
allgemein protestiert man natürlich
immer wieder gegen die waffenlieferung
aus dem westen auch öffentlich man wird
auch nicht müde zu wiederholen dass
diese waffenlieferung natürlich auch
gute militärische ziele seien für
russland
präsident putin hat vor drei tagen hier
nochmal und frankreichs präsident mark
rohr gesprochen hat nochmal seine sicht
der dinge ihn versucht zu erklären und
für putin gebe es eine lösung wie der
westen einwirken könne in dem konflikt
er hat mal gesagt
das ist eigentlich ganz einfach sein
müsse mehr druck auf see lenski ausüben
und seiner armee keine waffen mehr
liefern das ist die lage aus moskauer
sicht ganz herzlichen dank nach moskau
und nach washington der krieg reicht bis
zu uns nach deutschland auf ganz vielen
ebenen es ist nicht mehr ungewöhnlich im
alltag ukrainerinnen und ukrainer zu
treffen vor allem ukrainerinnen viele
mit kindern die versuchen hier in
sicherheit mit dem klar zu kommen was
sie erleben mussten und gleichzeitig
nach einer perspektive suchen für sich
und die kinder stefanie dosch nimmt uns
mit ins café ukraine nach berlin
sie kommen aus mario pohl venezia kiew
die flucht spielte sie in diese küche in
berlin
gemeinsam kochen sie nun gerichte der
heimat
ihre männer blieben zurück zerrissener
familien
ich war noch nie so lange ohne mein mann
wir sind seit 33 jahren zusammen und nun
am alexanderplatz organisieren die
frauen das café ukraine einmal in der
woche es sind starke frauen die bis vor
kurzem ein gutes leben hatten familie
eine karriere
sowie xenia bocón in einem startup für
anlageberatung
die situation hat mein leben zerstört
hat meine pläne hoffnung und nicht nur
für mich auch für meine familie meine
sohn manny neffen sie haben gerade die
universität abgeschlossen und jetzt sind
sie soldaten
zehn jahre floh mit ihrem 14 jährigen
sohn ross sein freund neben ihm kam vor
vier jahren mit seiner mutter aus moskau
nach deutschland ukrainisch russische
freundschaft in einer küche in berlin
bei putin sind sie sich einig
ich hege keinen hass gegen russen wie
meinen freund aber ich verabscheue alles
was die russische regierung gerade tut
dieser krieg
[Musik]
aber alle meine freundin in russland in
die sind jetzt total gegen das was jetzt
passiert im café ukraine wird gegessen
gebastelt diskutiert gespielt die
geflohenen frauen denken sich workshops
aus die berliner stadtmission
unterstützt mit lebensmitteln und räumen
die ukrainerin die hier angekommen sind
teils so oder so haben wir alle viele
schätze und
viel können und genau das denken sie an
diese ressourcen die sie haben schenken
sie uns im grunde genommen ja
natalie flow aus mario pohl schulte dort
manager nun gibt sie ihr wissen hier
weiter es lenkt ab bis sie wieder allein
ist
dann überkommt einen erneut dieser angst
und unruhe und du erkennst deine
situation und denkst was machst du jetzt
weiter wie lebst du weiter was ist
morgen wie ist es möglich dass sein land
ein volk getötet wird einfach getötet
auch dass die sängerin flow aus kiew
jetzt trägt sie die stimme ihres landes
hinein in das café ukraine und für einen
moment ist es so als wären sie nicht
hier sondern zu hause
ein tag im café ukraine am
alexanderplatz mit ganz vielen
bewundernswerten menschen wir bleiben
noch beim großen thema krieg gegen die
ukraine jetzt mit johanna christian und
da blicken wir noch einmal auf das
deutsch ukrainische verhältnis bei dem
die zeichen auf entspannung stehen der
ukrainische präsident zealand ski hat
bundeskanzler chance konkret für den 9
mai nach kiew eingeladen zum tag des
sieges über nazi-deutschland scholz die
einladung annehmen wird ist nicht
bekannt ein termin der dagegen sicher
ist am sonntag will sich der
bundeskanzler in einer fernsehansprache
zum ukraine krieg und dem ende des
zweiten weltkriegs äußern hier im zdf um
19 uhr 30
deutschland liefert 7 hochmoderne
panzerhaubitzen des typs 2000 an die
ukraine das kündigte
bundesverteidigungsminister in lambrecht
bei einem besuch in der slowakei an die
panzerhaubitze ist ein schweres
artilleriegeschütz dem mit einer kanone
die reichweite beträgt bis zu 40
kilometer bereits nächste woche sollen
ukrainische soldaten in idar oberstein
an den haubitzen ausgebildet werden wann
genau sie ausgeliefert werden ist
dagegen noch unklar
aktuell werden die haubitzen in der
heeres instandsetzung repariert
in der ukrainischen hafenstadt mario
pohl gab es heute einen zweiten versuch
die verbliebenen zivilisten aus dem
umkämpften stahlwerk zu evakuieren laut
ukrainischen angaben konnten dabei 50
menschen gerettet werden ukrainische
kämpfer warfen den russischen truppen
vor die dafür vereinbarte mehrstündige
waffenruhe gebrochen zu haben
ein fahrzeug das zivilisten habe abholen
wollen sei mit einer panzerabwehrrakete
beschossen worden in den vergangenen
tagen sollen laut ukrainischen
präsidialamt insgesamt 500 zivilisten
aus dem stahlwerk in sicherheit gebracht
worden seien
die eu ringt weiter um eine einigung zum
geplanten öl-embargo gegen russland um
ganz ministerpräsident orban machte
heute deutlich sein land brauche
mindestens fünf jahre um auf russisches
öl verzichten zu können wie hart die
verhandlungen verlaufen zeigt auch die
wortwahl urbans ein öl-embargo
bezeichnete er atombombe die auf die
ungarische wirtschaft abgeworfen werde
bei den kommunal und regionalwahlen im
vereinigten königreich musste die
konservative partei von premier johnson
zum teil herbe verluste hinnehmen
die wahlen waren auch ein stimmungstest
für den angeschlagenen premier johnson
sprach von einer harten nacht den
ergebnissen zufolge verlieren die tories
einige langjährige hochburgen an die
oppositionelle labour partei bei den
regionalwahlen in nordirland stehen die
endgültigen ergebnisse noch aus nach
ersten auszählungen könnte hier die pro
ihre shin steyn stärkste kraft werden
schönfeld tritt für eine
wiedervereinigung nordirlands mit der
republik irland ein und will darüber
abstimmen lassen
martin huber wird neuer generalsekretär
der csu das gab bayerns
ministerpräsident söder bekannt der 44
jährige promovierte
politikwissenschaftler war bislang
abgeordneter im bayerischen landtag als
csu-generalsekretär soll er unter
anderem den landtagswahlkampf im
kommenden jahr managen huber folgt auf
stephan mayer der vor drei tagen
überraschend als generalsekretär
zurückgetreten war hatte dafür
gesundheitliche gründe genannt mayer
stand allerdings gleichzeitig in der
kritik weil er einen journalisten
bedroht haben soll
und jetzt ein ganz anderes thema das ihn
aber dennoch bekannt vorkommen dürfte
hoch aber nicht mehr sehr hoch das ist
ein unterschied und das ist die neue
risikobewertung des robert koch
instituts seit heute wir sind damit ja
bei den gefahren durch das corona virus
und es wird höchste zeit für mindestens
eine zwischenbilanz was heißt das jetzt
wo stehen wir und was kommt noch viele
fragen die pandemie ist nicht vorbei
sagt das lka aber die tendenz ist
eindeutig und sie geht in die richtige
richtung cornelia strauß hat mehr dazu
der frühling bringt ein gefühl der
leichtigkeit mit sich das war schon
früher so und scheint seit der pandemie
noch stärker zu sein kein abstand keine
masken es wirkt als sei die gefahr vor
dem virus und einer damit verbundenen
erkrankungen nicht mehr da der blick auf
die zahlen sagt etwas anderes die
inzidenz ist nach wie vor sehr hoch
würde es die testpflicht noch geben wäre
sie vermutlich noch höher der wert ist
also hoch und doch kaum aussagekräftig
und dennoch aus sicht vieler
wissenschaftler ist das gefühl der
entspannung trotzdem erlaubt jeder von
uns kennt jemanden der irgendwie
infiziert ist das ist ein wichtiger
punkt und man sollte das nicht auf die
leichte schulter nehmen das ist eine
ernste erkrankung nach wie vor aber der
anteil der sehr schwer erkranken der ist
jetzt eben etwa ein zehntel so hoch in
der mikrowelle wird ein früher in
vellmar deswegen ist eben die krankheit
anders zu beurteilen
wissenschaft und politik stützen sich
jetzt viel mehr auf die zahl derer die
ins krankenhaus eingewiesen werden und
die die intensivmedizinisch behandelt
werden müssen am anfang der pandemie
weil jeder verhinderte infektion auch
eine verhinderte erkrankung seitdem ein
großteil der bevölkerung geimpft ist ist
die sogenannte immunkompetenz der
gesellschaft so groß dass die gefahr
einer schweren erkrankung deutlich
gesunken ist
die krankenhäuser sind aber immer noch
hoch belastet weil er nach geräte
operationen jetzt da sind und weil immer
noch sich tatsächlich viel abspielt aber
die lage ist jetzt natürlich auch in
bezug auf den sommer eine andere als wir
sie schon hatten bei der del-tabelle
wenn ich erinnere waren die
intensivstationen folge mussten
patientinnen und patienten in andere
bundesländer verlegen da war es schon
sehr kritisch für ältere menschen
chronisch kranke und solche mit
erkrankungen des immunsystems stellt das
virus nach wie vor die größte gefahr dar
impfungen bieten den besten schutz davon
sind viele mediziner überzeugt
entsprechend planen sie für den
kommenden herbst diese gruppen jetzt
besonders zu schützen durch intensivere
impfschema ta wird bereits empfohlen und
ist möglich und auf diese risikogruppe
müssen wir auch mit blick auf den
nächsten winter ein besonderes augenmerk
legen für uns lohnt es sich deshalb uns
vorzubereiten dh eine poster kampagne
durchführen zu können neue impfstoffe
kontinuierlich anzupassen und zu
verbessern aktuell bewertet das robert
koch institut die gefahren des corona
virus geringer als bisher also ein
bestimmtes risiko ist noch da aber sie
trauen es den bürgern und bürgerinnen zu
dass sie mit dem risiko auch
verantwortungsbewusst umgehen denn wir
haben ja auch tests nach wie vor jeder
kann sich nach wie vor testen man muss
immer dieses gesamtbild betragen der
frühling bringt ein gefühl der
leichtigkeit mit sich wie sich der
herbst entwickeln wird darüber sind sich
wissenschaft und politik offenbar einig
hängt davon ab wie viele menschen sich
weiter impfen lassen
nichts gegen das schöne schleswig
holstein dort sind übermorgen
landtagswahlen aber der wirkliche
bundespolitische wumms könnte wohl eher
eine woche später kommen wenn nrw wählt
erstmal leben dort rund elf millionen
wahlberechtigte mehr als im norden
nordrhein westfalen ist das
bevölkerungsreichste bundesland und dann
sehen die umfragen sehr nach
kopf-an-kopf-rennen aus um die macht in
düsseldorf
gucken wir mal auf das
zdf-politbarometer dazu von heute und
danach liegt die cdu von
ministerpräsident hendrik wüst mit 30
prozent knapp vor der spd
von herausforderer thomas kutschaty mit
28 prozent wenn am sonntag landtagswahl
wäre die grünen würden stark zulegen auf
18 prozent fdp und fdp kämen jeweils 7
prozent die linke 3 prozent das bild
zeigt zweierlei auf einen blick es wird
knapp und es kommt vor allem auf die
grünen an 1 dominik müller russe
es ist auf den ersten blick kein grünes
tara hier im ruhrgebiet dass die grüne
politprominenz an diesem tag betritt auf
ihrer wahlkampftour wieder die region
noch handwerksbetriebe im allgemeinen
doch in der bäckerei wickenburg in
bochum kommt der strom für die backöfen
bald aus solarkraft vom dach stellt sich
heraus und in nordrhein westfalen werden
die grünen wohl bald als königsmacher
entscheiden können wer mit ihnen am
tisch sitzen und reagieren darf ob nun
die union oder die spd es ist am ende
fast unentscheiden tweer in der
staatskanzlei einzieht welcher mann wir
wollen so stark werden wie noch nie bei
einer landtagswahl hier in nordrhein
westfalen das ist unsere aussage
selbstbewusst und eigenständig diesen
wahlkampf zu führen und ja wir geben
eine richtung vor traditionell stehen
sich in nrw zwei lager gegenüber schwarz
gelb auf der einen und rot grün auf der
anderen seite die neuen zahlen des zdf
politbarometers stimmen
spd-spitzenkandidat thomas kutschaty
heute morgen deshalb optimistisch dass
ihr dieser mann ist für den sich die
grünen schlussendlich entscheiden werden
da warten wir erstmal ab wie die wahl
tatsächlich ausgehen wird es ist ein
kopf an kopf rennen die letzte umfrage
sagt ja es kann für rot-grün durchaus
reichen manche sagen dreierbündnisse
aber da bin ich ganz gelassen warten wir
doch erst mal wie die wählerinnen und
wähler entscheiden ich habe es noch nie
erlebt dass eine wahl so knapp in den
umfragen vorhersagen gewesen ist wie
jetzt in nordrhein westfalen ganz vorne
sehen die umfragen die cdu von
ministerpräsident hendrik wüst und der
würde am liebsten zusammen mit der fdp
weiterregieren wie gehabt für
schwarz-gelb wird es allerdings wohl
kaum reichen doch vielleicht kommen ja
auch grüne königsmacher nicht um ihn
herum mit die union nur deutlich genug
vor der spd liegt in
diesen tagen werben wir natürlich erst
mal für ein starkes ergebnis für die cdu
für unsere kandidatinnen und kandidaten
und ich werbe auch um das vertrauen der
menschen auch in zukunft eine regierung
anführen zu können alles weitere und das
gebietet auch der respekt vor den
wählerinnen und wählern entscheiden wir
nach der wahl falls es doch ein
dreierbündnis bräuchte zum regieren dann
könnten sie ins spiel kommen die fdp je
nach dem stimmten sie bereit für jamaika
oder einer ampel alleine schon um die
ungeliebten grünen einzufangen
für uns ist es wichtig dass es keine
koalition gibt wo die grünen alleine mit
einem partner unterwegs und ich glaube
dass wir fürs land nicht gut an ihnen
kommt niemand vorbei so sieht es im
moment aus der die meist regieren wird
in nrw die grünen haben es wohl in der
hand
so gestern die ölkonzerne deren manager
mit dollarzeichen in den augen
herumlaufen ob ihrer gewinne in
kriegszeiten heute hanna eine weitere
branche und zwar die rüstungsindustrie
da sieht es angesichts des kriegs und
den damit verbundenen ausrüstungs plänen
wenig überraschend ähnlich aus heute
haben rheinmetall und heckler & koch
ihre quartalszahlen vorgelegt und sina
mainitz sie haben auch schon mal einen
ausblick gegeben wie das jahr
weitergehen könnte das jahr könnte sehr
gut für diese unternehmen weitergehen
wenn denn das sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr in höhe von 100 milliarden
euro tatsächlich kommen sollte und die
waffenlieferungen an die nato staaten
die wegen des ukraine krieges aufrüsten
weitergehen deutsche rüstungskonzerne
haben hochkonjunktur
so bitter das auch klingen mag die
äußeren umstände und auch das gewisse
umdenken lassen die gewinne jener
konzerne sprudeln die aus der
sicherheits- oder verteidigungsbranche
kommen so lägen seit jahresbeginn die
aktien des rüstungs und autozulieferer
rheinmetall um 108 prozent zu
rheinmetall hat der bundesregierung eine
liste mit rüstungsgütern im wert von 42
milliarden euro hinterlegt anders herum
lässt sich am beispiel des thüringer
unternehmens jenoptik beobachten dass
eine firma gnadenlos an der börse
abgestraft wird wenn sie ihre
rüstungssparte verkauft auch jenoptik
war im bereich sicherheit und
verteidigung zog sich aber zurück ein
schritt der bei den aktionären in diesen
zeiten nicht gut ankommt seit
jahresbeginn verliert die aktie des
unternehmens mehr als 30 prozent in den
80er jahren wehten die fahnen mit der
friedenstaube und es hieß frieden
schaffen ohne waffen seit kriegsbeginn
gegen die ukraine fühlen sich nun die
rüstungskonzerne gesellschaftlich
deutlich akzeptierte weil eine ganze
welt ordnung ins wanken geraten ist die
neue zeitrechnung macht einiges möglich
was bis vor kurzem noch undenkbar schien
bei den rüstungskonzernen auch
finanziell danke china nach frankfurt
die zahl der beschäftigten in kurzarbeit
ist im april laut ifo institut deutlich
gesunken den stärksten rückgang habe es
in kontakt intensiven branchen gegeben
die sich von dem der pandemie erholen
würden zum beispiel im gastgewerbe nach
angaben des ifo instituts waren im
vergangenen monat die 126 tausende
menschen in kurzarbeit betroffen waren
damit 1,3 prozent der beschäftigten im
vormonat waren es noch 2,1 prozent
der letzte teil der reise ist vermutlich
der nervigste für matthias maurer weil
irgendwie normal und vergleichsweise
nahe an der erde
deutschlands in den letzten monaten
einziger mensch im all fliegt jetzt im
moment aus florida zurück nach köln nach
einer bilderbuchlandung im golf von
mexiko maurer war der vierte deutsche
hier auf der internationalen raumstation
die in etwa 90 minuten einmal um den
erdball rast und trotz all ihrer mängel
als technische und nationen verbindende
großtat gilt susanne freitag berichtet
unmittelbar vor diesem moment spürten
die astronauten das dreifache ihres
eigenen gewichts als druck auf ihrem
körper das ist ungefähr so wie ein sehr
krasser achterbahn looping dauert aber
zehn minuten am stück ein guter margen
wird empfohlen auch beim splash daun im
atlantik
[Applaus]
aber da ist er matthias maurer und wenn
er so lacht dann geht es ihm gut sagt
ein guter freund nicht mehr schwerelos
nach sechs monaten der astronaut
reinhold ewald ist heute in köln um
matthias maurer zu empfangen er erinnert
sich noch gut an seine rückkehr auf die
erde also insgesamt muss man sagen dass
das gleichgewichtsorgan ein bisschen
wackelig ist man nimmt ecken mit wann
dreht zu plötzlich sich vorne überzeugen
das heißt es einen richtig also dann
runter da ist nur vor wenn man die
schuhe von oben zu machen können sechs
monate lang hat matthias maurer auf der
iss gelebt und geforscht die tage durch
getaktet mit wissenschaftlichen menden
er testete wie sich flüssigkeiten hier
oben verhalten was die schwerelosigkeit
mit dem menschlichen körper macht kann
die analyse von atem gas bei der
krankheitsdiagnose helfen außerdem hat
er beton gemischt um den baustoff
ökologischer zu machen wir können hier
erkenntnisse gewinnen die uns dann
helfen den beton prozess auf dem boden
zu optimieren und wenn uns das gelingt
dann können wir hoffentlich auch unsere
klimaziele in stückchen besser erfüllen
die iss war immer ein symbol der
friedlichen zusammenarbeit im all doch
während marsmission brach der krieg in
der ukraine aus die zerstörung ist von
oben sichtbar russland drohte die
zusammenarbeit beim projekt iss zu
beenden die astronauten haben den krieg
nie öffentlich kommentiert bei einer
pressekonferenz im all wurde matthias
maurer trotzdem deutlich
ich möchte dass über dieses friedliche
symbol der zusammenarbeit die iss auf
der erde mehr nachgedacht wird dass
entscheidungsträger unser schönes europa
und unserem schönen planeten zu einem
friedlichen ort der kooperation machen
jetzt kommt er zurück im institut für
raumfahrtmedizin in köln ist alles
vorbereitet matthias maurer macht
erstmal eine astoria
blutuntersuchung kreislauf atmung
alles
immunsystem und in der zeit kann er sich
hier halt aufhalten
hier werden fähnchen vorbereitet zum
winken und jubeln für eine würdige
rückkehr in die schwerkraft
nach einer mission mit dem tollen namen
cosmic es für alle all und astro fans
die dokumentation dienstreise ins
universum matthias maurers mission gibt
es bei zdf heute und auch alle anderen
auf der erde können da noch was lernen
sagt ihnen der name finn kliemann etwas
an der antwort auf diese frage lässt
sich ganz schnell ablesen zu welcher
generation sie gehören und wie sehr sie
im netz unterwegs sind die einen werden
sagen nie gehört wer soll das sein für
die anderen ist finn kliemann bisweilen
schon so eine art idol ein vorbild einer
dem aber tausendfach gefolgt wird der
trend setzt und der dabei viel verkauft
klamotten kunst landleben urlaub in
ferienwohnungen und corona masken alles
immer mit dem zusatz es sei bei ihm und
von ihm besonders nachhaltig besonders
solidarisch besonders fair jan
böhmermann und das zdf-magazin royal
gucken heute abend hinter die fassade
die recherchen zeigen anhand von
internen e-mails firmen dokumenten und
chat protokollen einen youtube
tausendsassa der sich mitten in der
pandemie freut das zitat krise auch geil
sein kann
folgt man den recherchen geil vor allem
fürs geschäft bei dem so der vorwurf
fleißig umdeklariert und irre geführt
wurde kliemann weist einige betrugs
vorwürfe als falsch zurück bei anderen
müsse er sich entschuldigen es lohnt
sich also im zdf jetzt dabei zu bleiben
erst die heute show zdf magazin royal
und gegen 0.15 gibt's dann unser
heute-journal update mit nazan gremien
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen
abend
[Musik]
guten abend da kommt von nordwesten eine
kleine kaltfront heran die zieht morgen
weiter richtung mittelgebirge und wird
dabei immer schwächer die kaltfront
bringt regen mit das merken wir schon
heute nacht hier an der nordsee küste
südlich der donau gibt es noch einige
schauer sonst ist es heute nach zum teil
auch klar und die temperaturen sinken
auf werte zwischen 11 und 4 grad und
steigen morgen dann auf 19 bis 24 grad
ausnahmen sind aber der alpenrand und
auch die küsten von nord- und ostsee da
bleibt es bei 14 bis 18 grad kühler und
in norddeutschland liegt das eben an der
kaltfront die dann durchgezogen sein
wird nachmittags locker die wolken
hierbei nordwesten wieder auf die
kaltfront nicht morgen mittag etwa
zwischen dem rhein unter oder da gibt es
also regenschauer und gewitter
zwischendurch werden sie aber auch mal
die sonne sehen zwischen dem odenwald
und dem oberrhein dagegen gibt es morgen
fiel sonntag anders südlich der donau da
geht's weiter kräftige regenschauer und
gewitter die ziehen sich dann aber im
laufe des sonntags immer weiter richtung
alpenrand zurück und in norddeutschland
wird das ein sehr sonniger muttertag bei
temperaturen von 14 bis 21 grad im süden
ist es schon ein bisschen milder und
dann kommt die neue woche und damit
kommt ein neues hoch und wir werden dann
nicht mehr auf der kalten ost sondern
auf der deutlich wärmeren westseite
liegen und das bedeutet für die
temperaturen der nächsten woche sie
werden ansteigen zum teil bis auf 27
grad guten abend